hi there steve kaufman here um i'm going
to uh focus in this uh video
on um
a question that comes up all the time
and that is
you know don't you forget your by the
way this is london school of economics
my son went there so i got a t-shirt
from him
um
the question is you know don't you
forget your languages
or how do you maintain your languages
that's a very common question and i'm
going to get into that but first i want
to address another question that i get
all the time and that is
you know i'm very interested in
languages i want to do a job i want to
have a job which will involve me with
languages or things of that nature what
do you recommend
so let's deal with that second question
first because i can deal with it very
quickly in my experience the more
languages you speak the more
opportunities you have the more
connections you can make the more
opportunities are going to come your way
however
i'm not aware of many jobs where you can
go and say look at me i speak all these
languages
please give me a job generally speaking
the language skill is a secondary it's a
it's something that you kind of keep
uh in the background that's going to
help you do better that's going to help
you connect with more people it's going
to make it more likely that you'll find
a job or that you'll have opportunities
in your business but i always take in
the position that it's not something
that you lead with it's not something
that's going to necessarily get you the
job it's almost like an added bonus that
the employer
gets or it's an addis added the trump
card that you have that's going to help
you succeed
you have to have something else
whether you're interested in doing
business whether you're interested in
music whether you're interested in
whatever it might be you need to develop
that other skill i don't think unless
you want to be an interpreter
or a translator or something that's very
specifically or a language teacher uh
the language is just a tremendous bonus
that you have in addition to what has to
be your main skill or
even personality traits like being
thorough and and doing what you say
you're going to do and and being
hard-working and and giving more than
you take and all of these other good
things that i think
enable people to build up
the goodwill that leads to success
okay now let's get on to the subject of
forgetting languages don't you forget
languages how do you not forget
languages the simple answer here is i
don't forget languages i have not
forgotten a language
and i think there are several reasons
for this
first of all
my method of learning is massive input
if you look at my statistics
on check i should have looked them up
but i've probably read the equivalent of
i don't know how many books
and everything that i've read i've
listened to
um
you know i don't know how many it's got
to be five six ten books worth of check
that i've listened to
in the last nine months or so that i've
read and listened to and saved words and
so so i'm i'm exposing my brain to this
massive
deluge of content and and this is
building a solid base in the language if
i were simply trying to study word lists
or trying to memorize the clension
tables
or learn grammar rules i i think those
things you can forget those are the
kinds of things that you remember for a
test uh but very quickly forget i've had
the experience myself i've studied
say russian or czech you know declension
tables uh for nouns
and i think i have them for a day or two
and then they're gone again
however uh phrases that i've heard uh
many times and words that i've seen many
times
these combination of words with the noun
and the right ending
combined with a certain preposition
uh all of these things start to become
part of
you know strong you know patterns that
are built in the brain and we don't
forget them
so
the first answer is if you don't want to
forget languages learn them the hard way
if you want in other words invest the
time
put the time into enough exposure to the
language that you are building these
sediments
the these this accumulated experience
with the language in your brain
the second thing is
i
am not bothered by the fact that when i
start up in the language that i haven't
spoken for a while that i'm rusty that
doesn't bother me at all
in fact i'm going to do another video on
the importance of low expectations
i think people who expect too much of
themselves end up being frustrated
lose confidence
you know lose interest whatever
i mean if i haven't spoken swedish or
spanish or something for a while i'm
going to stumble when i start up again
and sometimes people come at me on
youtube and oh you don't speak islam is
very well you made this other mistake
and stuff yeah sure whatever it does
bother me
uh i know that if i were then to be put
in a situation for a day or two or three
where i had to use that language
regularly and i was once again listening
to it all the time and everything that
was in my brain was starting to revive
that i would do fine
in fact i've had the experience that and
i've mentioned this before that if i
leave a language and study some other
language when i come back to that first
language that i left i'm actually better
in the language because my overall
language learning and language using
capability has improved by learning
other languages and the fact that i
stumble out of the gate so to speak
for the first day or two
so what
i have no particular expectations i know
that in any language
you know a second third fourth fifth
language that you speak you'll do better
on some days than on other days
and that's what it is and some days it's
tiring and some days
it's frustrating to try and look for
words that you can't find and you get
annoyed and you would like to retreat
back into your native language and other
days you're just
walking on water and doing very well and
so whichever happens to be the case that
day that's good enough for me i don't
don't go in there with any particular
expectations
so and when i hear people say oh yes you
know my father came over from the old
country and he hasn't speaking spoken
polish or italian in 50 years and now he
can't speak it
i kind of tend to take that with a grain
of salt i think if that particular
father were
set back into a polish italian
portuguese chinese whatever environment
that that language would come back to
him if he'd been exposed to it for 10 or
20 or 30 years as a young person and
then had been away from it for 30 40
years when he or she goes back to that
environment it'll come right back
very very quickly so to me
i don't forget languages
how do i maintain them if i quickly if i
need to
get up to speed like sometimes i'll be
asked to appear on a mandarin chinese
television program here in vancouver
i'll get out some audio books some cds
i'll listen to them i'll do a better
reading give myself some exposure
one thing i certainly don't look at is
grammar books
if you want to get yourself back to
speed you need more exposure let's not
say i don't look at grammar books i will
occasionally look at grammar books
thumb through them so to speak but
to get yourself back up to speed
you need a lot of exposure and i've been
away from it for a while the first night
out with native speakers you might
stumble a bit but you're
very quickly right back in the groove at
least that has been my experience so
there you have it on how not to forget
or how to maintain your languages thanks
for listening